so phil murphy until a couple years ago
was just some creepy finance guy now
he's the king of new jersey so we had
phil murphy on at the beginning of
corona and i asked him how do you get
the right to order all these people
around like they're your servants and
here's what he said
the bill of rights as you well know
protects americans right and shrines
their right to practice their religion
as they see fit and to congregate
together to assemble peacefully
by what authority did you nullify the
bill of rights in issuing this order
how do you have the power of that
that's above my peg ray tucker so i
wasn't uh i wasn't thinking of the bill
of rights when we did this
given this he was an early adopter to
fascism there's someone running against
him in new jersey overwhelmingly
democratic state but republicans have
one in the past so we're going to talk
now to jack citarelli he's running
against phil murphy for governor of new
jersey which is this year he joins us mr
shirley thank you so much
you know it was almost 30 years ago that
jim florio lost a democrat in a
democratic state because he just went
way too far why do you think you can
do the same to this guy
phil murphy's done the same thing tucker
he's gone way too far left he's very
extreme and you know a year and a half
ago on this very show as you just told
us he said the bill of rights that's
above my pay grade uh it's not funny but
worse than that he uh told the highest
tax people in the nation if taxes are
your issue we're probably not your state
he's basically telling new jerseyans to
leave
i mean
this guy and i know it's i think you've
got a million more democrats than
republicans in the state but is it your
sense that like they've got to be
democrats this is just this guy's too
much he's incompetent he's nasty and
he's just totally authoritarian i mean
do you think
you have honestly a shot to win
a majority of democrats in new jersey uh
tucker are fiscally conservative and
socially moderate and this guy this guy
is just way too extreme and so we've won
six of the last 10 governor races in
this state and no democratic incumbent
governor has been reelected in more than
40 years we're right where we need to be
with eight days to go
i mean this guy makes jim florio look
completely reasonable are you worried
about fraud in new jersey maybe a
rhetorical question
we're voting in person this year and
we've got a great legal team on the
ground in those areas that have been
trouble spots in the past but no i'm not
and i don't want anybody staying home
because they think a republican can't
win or it's rigged
we're very confident in this year's
election system and we're confident to
win on november 2nd
jack should have really i i don't even
know everything you stand for i know
you're not this guy murphy he's really
loathsome it's just the worst so
godspeed we're rooting for you jack
chitarelli of new jersey hope you can do
it
thank you thank you tucker we can